[Music]  season four of jersey shore is on the  air now and uh there are these  persistent rumors at the show  uh that the producers of the show are  looking to replace the current cast with  a whole new crew you keep hearing these  rumors they want to replace the cast get  new people and we looked into it  and we found out the rumors true  once again we were able to get some of  the secret audition tapes for the new  cast  of jersey shore and there are some very  impressive candidates  paul rudd  i want to marry a guido  my ultimate dream is to move to jersey  find a nice hot juiced tan guy and  live my life  anne hathaway  tall completely jacked steroids like  multiple growth hormones  that's the type i'm attracted to  i'm gonna turd in my pants  how do you go into a jacuzzi with a  thong and a bra  wear a thong bikini  dennis haysbert  the situation  wants me to jump on a grenade  but i'm not going to jump on a grenade  for the situation  dennis hayes is amazing